Where is the soul stone you should know
It extracts a terrible price
How is it, you know this place so well a lifetime ago I too
Saw the stones. I
Even held one in my hand
But it cast me out
Banished me here
guiding others to a treasure I cannot possess
What you seek lies in front of you as does what you fear
What's this the price
Soul holds a special place among the Infinity stones
You might say it is a certain wisdom
Tell me what it needs to ensure that whoever possesses it understands its power the
Stone
Demands a sacrifice of what in order to take the stone. You must lose that which you love
The soul for a soul
Everybody is Charlie you probably heard about the huge red skull news last night
The Russos were doing live commentary. Someone asked them about red skull in this soulstone scene
They revealed that because Thanos took the stone successfully
he was freed in the
Process and is now free to leave or mere implying that he's alive again
Like he's returned to the world of the living and free to pursue an infinity stone as he pleases
Like he's going to continue seeking the Infinity stones. I did not expect him to return after this movie
So we got to break this down. This means a couple big things
But if you're new to the channel, be sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
There's a new brand of that Infinity Ward giveaway that I'll explain at the end of the video, too
So the big thing here is that we can kind of confirm what happened when Thanos
Sacrificed Gamora so it explains some of the mechanics the soul stone in the MCU
It's a little bit different from the soul stone in the comics
But they've confirmed that this soul stones power is controlling life and death so they know
sacrifices that which he loves Gamora gets the soul stone but in the process he trades a soul for a soul
Like the Red Skull says so you have to imagine that when Thanos gets ported down here and he finds it in his hand
There's a deleted moment up on this hill here where Red Skull is cackling in delight because you have to remember that
He's a genius. He has all the same powers as Captain America
so, of course
He'd probably be spending all the years that he was trapped there
Finding a way to get out meaning he needed someone to release him by sacrificing someone else
So the roosters are saying that Red Skull is coming back
there are three easy ways that I think you can do that including a really big but really short
oh crap moment during Avengers 4 but also this whole big red skull twist also is a good way of
Explaining how they can bring Gamora back because we know she's coming back for guardians 3
meaning that in Avengers 4 regardless of alternate universes second Infinity Gauntlet
however
The Avengers fix the universe. You still need to get this Gamora out of this soul stone in order to do that
You have to trade a soul for a soul
The easiest way to do that and deal with a nose is a trade a nose for Gomorrah
but the problem with that is is that either Thanos would have to sacrifice himself or
Someone would have to love Thanos so they could sacrifice him because that's part of the rules
You have to sacrifice that which you love and nebula would be a good candidate for that
But it doesn't seem like she loves Thanos so I don't know how that would work
So it's still speculation about how they deal with nanos ultimately because they'll defeat him
that's the whole idea Avengers four is gonna have a more hopeful ending where they fix the universe in the Marvel movies are gonna
Effectively put Thanos on a shelf somewhere for a long long time like they spent the last 10 years setting him up
It's not like he's gonna continue to be a super big character if they bring him back after
Avengers 4 it would be as like a funny
You know really quick moment during Secret Wars where you have all these different
Realities blending together like, oh here's a universe where Thanos was doing something else and survive the end of Avengers 4
so even if it isn't gonna be famous at the end of Avengers 4
Somebody has to sacrifice themselves or sacrifice something else to get Gamora back
Hopefully it doesn't have to be Captain America because the person that you sacrificed to get Gamora back doesn't necessarily have to have any pre-existing
Relationship with her like fan OHS didn't know anything about Red Skull before this Gamora didn't know him
It just means trading a soul for a soul
But the easy ways you bring Red Skull back like we're so say he's free to leave or mere free to pursue an infinity stone
that implies that they intend on paying that off like he actually will go seek some of the Infinity stones after this but because of
The way the actors and the producers have been talking about the level of craziness ramping up and Avengers 4 it seemingly confirms
Multiverse we learned about quantum energy ant-man and the wasp post-credit scene all the promise of all that crazy
unpredictable time travel the
easiest and most rewarding
way
I think to bring the Red Skull back is if there's a moment during Avengers 4 just a really quick scene where they're
Cycling through other realities just trying to see and get clues about how to fix things in their own
Reality and they find a darkest timeline where Red Skull really did
Assemble all six of the Infinity stones just a really quick moment where Captain America is like hell no
And they just cycle to the next reality
Because you have to imagine the run time is gonna be about the same is infinity war
so it's not like they're gonna travel between hundreds and hundreds of different realities second easiest way if they don't want to do darkest timeline,
Infinity Gauntlet Red Skull is that you finally have our
Captain America kill him at some point to end his arc and be like
This is the end of the Red Skull or three if they want to leave him for another space space movie
you could have him become a minor villain or an antihero during a Captain Marvel sequel or
Nova, or one of the other future space-based movies in phase four phase five
But I think the ideas is that he's done as a main character
So there's not gonna be any huge Red Skull movie down the line. If or when he shows up again
It's gonna be like a holy crap moment like this soulstone scene, but that's probably about it
If you remember there was actually a plot in the comics where the Avengers fired
Ultron into deep space as a way to deal with them
he ended up surviving and taking over a mechanical race called the
Phalanx and turning them into his own private space army to attack the Kree with he became a plot point during anihilation
Conquest so it was like him showing up many comic book arcs later like surprise bitches
You thought I was dead but I'm alive they've kind of done that with this soulstone scene already
So like I said when I think Red Skull comes back
He's a relatively minor plot point but rewarding for the fans like if you've been paying attention this whole time
It'll be a really cool Easter egg. Next big question. I know you're asking if he leaves for Mir
How does he leave because he's there by himself
I think the idea is is that he's been here for many many years guiding people to the soulstone
Unsuccessfully, like people have tried and failed to get the soul stone. They would have brought their own spacecraft
So the planet is probably littered with spacecraft or the bones of spacecraft of the people who tried to get the soul stone
So it's not like there isn't anything on the planet. It's just obviously they left that for future movies to deal with
So let me know in the comments Red Skull comes back in a future movie. How do you want them to bring him back?
There's a new round of the infinity war blu-ray giveaway
All you have to do to enter that is be a subscriber and leave a comment on the video
There'll be a whole bunch more stuff like this red skull reveal on that commentary track
So in a couple weeks when that drops, I'll do some new videos about that, too
But leave all your requests in the comments below some of you been requesting a cloak-and-dagger video
So I will do cloak and dagger finale in season 2
Tonight while you wait for everything click here for all those other Infinity Ward deleted scenes and click here to rewatch that venom trailer
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight